[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débats et de reportage comme tous les
soirs 18h et 22h sur public Sénas c'est
une journée décisive qui s'est joué au
Parlement et dans la rue lors de la
commission mixte paritaire débuté et
sénateurs sont tombés d'accord sur une
version commune de la réforme des
retraites le texte sera présenté demain
au Sénat puis à l'Assemblée nationale et
dans la rue c'était la 8e journée de
mobilisation pour maintenir la pression
également sur les élus du peuple avec un
risque de radicalisation
et ça c'est extrêmement inquiétant on
voit fleurir les panneaux de personnes
qui disent si cette réforme pas passe je
ne voterai plus je vous propose deux
rendez-vous principaux dans ce sens
public dans une minute de sénateur une
sénatrice vont débattre de la version
définitive de la réforme issue de la
Commission mixparitaire et puis dans
trois quarts d'heure nos experts
constitutionnalistes politologues vont
analyser le climat de tension politique
et sociale qui s'impose dans le pays on
commencera notamment la dernière étude
du cevipov qui montre une défiance
grandissante des Français pour nos
institutions mais d'abord on résout le
joint en direct Jonathan Dupriez qui
était à l'Assemblée nationale vous allez
suivi pour nous cette CMP et cette
commission mixte paritaire qui a donc
été conclusive
absolument Thomas et il aura fallu près
de 9 heures au 14 parlementaires qui
étaient réunis dans cette CMP au Palais
Bourbon pour parvenir à un accord mais
il y avait en fait assez peu de suspense
sur l'issue de cette CMP comme on dit
parce que dit parlementaire sur les 14
votants qui étaient dans ce conclave
était favorable au texte principalement
DLR et des macronistes et donc ça et
bien à la sortie c'est une satisfaction
pour la droite sénatoriale qui plaide
depuis des années pour cette réforme des
retraites et on va écouter à ce sujet
René Paul Savary qui était le rapporteur
du texte au Sénat
et sur des fondements bien spécifiques
qui sont ceux du Sénat ou depuis quatre
ans nous disons que la mesure
d'efforts collectifs qui peut être
demandé et sera plus équitablement
réparti en jouant sur les deux bornes à
le savoir la borne d'âge avec le
décalage là et la borne concernant la
durée de cotisation en conséquence il y
a eu effectivement un rapprochement par
rapport à ce que proposait la majorité
sénatoriale et effectivement nous sommes
arrivés à un texte commun qui prend en
compte notamment les difficultés quand
on travaille plus longtemps d'usure
professionnelle au prise en compte de
mesures de justice sociale pour lequel
pour lequel ces mesures le Sénat a
particulièrement contribué monsieur
Jonathan il y a des dispositions
importantes qui ont été adoptées un peu
plus tôt dans la journée par cette CMP
voilà ça tombait au fil de la journée et
il y a eu notamment l'adoption de
l'expérimentation d'un CDI senior
exonéré de cotisation familiale la
création d'une surcotte pour les maires
de famille mais surtout le fameux
article 7 le cœur de la réforme qui
consacre le report de l'âge légal à la
retraite de 62 à 64 ans et cette mesure
et bien les députés de essénateurs de
gauche ils ont assisté un peu impuissant
selon peut dire à l'adoption de cette
disposition phare du texte réclamé de
longue date par la droite sénatoriale et
ça ça a provoqué un la colère de
certains parlementaires de gauche qui
voyait une combine en fait entre les LR
et les macronistes joués d'avance et
écouter la chef de fil des socialistes
Monique Lubin à ce sujet
quand on est arrivé ce matin tout était
fait mais bon ça n'est pas étonnant en
même temps alors nous nous avons repassé
tous les articles et bien évidemment
mais tout était fait bien sûr une CMP
c'est comme ça mais il faut surtout pas
faire croire aux gens qu'il y avait
encore des marges de manœuvre en CMP
aujourd'hui tout était réglé voilà c'est
un arrangement entre la droite et la
droite quoi on fait voilà
la droite
macroniste démontre qu'elle est de
droite au cas où on n'aurait pas encore
compris et la droite des républicains
s'accorde parfaitement avec la droite
macroniste et tout ça ça fait un projet
de droite la commission mixte paritaire
Jonathan aussi adopter un dispositif
carrière longue qui a fait polémique au
Palais Bourbon
oui ça fait polémique et puis les
journalistes aussi n'ont pas tout à fait
compris on a mis du temps à démêler les
fils certains parlementaires de la
majorité macroniste ont affirmé qu'en
fait tous les salariés ayant commencé en
dessous de 21 ans et répondant au
dispositif de carrière longue et bien il
pourrait partir après 43 à nuités sans
décote or le diable étant dans les
détails dans ce qui a été adopté en CMP
et bien ce pourrait être en fait un peu
plus pour certains en fonction de leur
date de naissance et ça ça ne va pas du
tout aux proches du député LR Aurélien
Pradier qui menace dès demain de ne pas
voter la réforme en séance publique
alors qu'en fait le gouvernement table
sur ces quelques voix LR il veut
grappiller toutes les voies possibles
pour adopter la réforme des retraites
sans passer en force écouter un proche
d'Aurélien Pradier
président du groupe Renaissance au Sénat
et sénateurs de la Côte-d'Or Olivier
Hainaut bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
c'est natures centriste du Nord
vice-président de la commission des
affaires sociales et Mathieu croissanto
utérus politique bonsoir Mathieu
Marie-Pierre de la ganterie je commence
avec vous quel bilan vous faites de
cette de cette journée pas de surprise
finalement c'est un peu aucune surprise
parce que nous l'avions déjà vu lors de
ce débat au Sénat il y a une alliance de
fête politique entre la droite et les
macronistes alors on peut le comprendre
du point de vue d'Emmanuel Macron
puisque il faut bien qu'il trouve une
majorité c'est plus douteux quant à ses
convictions mais ça fait longtemps que
j'ai renoncé à aller trouver donc
Emmanuel Macron c'est aligné sur la
droite du Sénat la commission
mixparitaire ça a été très bien expliqué
étant composé majoritairement de ces
deux composantes politiques tout ça a
été prévisible et effectivement une CMP
contrairement à ce qu'on a raconté on a
dit ah mais donc il y a pas eu de le
texte n'a pas été voté à l'assemblée
mais vous allez voir la CMP ça va être
le lieu de la discussion d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'il faut que ça reste
secret et pas public bon en fait on a
bien vu que tout ça était fait en amont
et que d'ailleurs qui a eu atteinte à la
clarté à la sincérité du débat
parlementaire en référence aux conseils
constitutionnel pourquoi dites-vous ça
parce que alors le Conseil
constitutionnel est très vigilant et
très attentif sur la façon dont se
déroule des débats et notamment il peut
censurer des des lois lorsque les débats
n'ont pas respecté la sincérité et la
clarté du débat en gros tout le monde a
pu s'exprimer enfin les conditions du
débat ont été correctes pour faire
simple parce que bon ici ce qu'on a vu
c'est que a été remis aux membres de la
commission mixparitaire des dizaines et
des dizaines de pages bon le projet est
assez fourni mais surtout des choses qui
avaient été réécrites c'est-à-dire ce
qu'on pourrait appeler d'habitude des
amendements bref des nouvelles
rédactions et donc penser que en
quelques minutes il est possible
d'expertiser une nouvelle rédaction pour
ensuite avoir un avis pivoté ce n'est
pas un travail parlementaire direct et
donc nous nous saisirons le Conseil
constitutionnel mais à chaque étape il
nous a semblé et il nous semble que la
clarté la sincérité du débat
parlementaire est en cause et donc est
un motif de censure François patri une
réponse là-dessus ensuite évidemment on
parlera du fond du texte et voilà de
votre avis sur l'importance de cette
réforme je vois bien sur la sincérité je
vois bien qu'un cours d'arguments sur le
fait que le texte était voté une fine
malgré
l'oppositionnum malgré l'opposition et
le blocage l'opposition c'est la
première fois que je vois remis en cause
une CMP et CMP j'en ai connu beaucoup ce
n'est que même connu sur la CSG hein qui
et qui a remis en cause après le thé de
la CSG toutes les CMP la CMP c'est pas
c'est pas 14 sénateurs qui tranchent
surtout c'est le Sénat et l'Assemblée
qui tous deux avertit de ce qui a été
voté mais c'est dans le même temps
ce sont quand même saisis ils le
connaissent le texte ils le connaissent
qui ont étudié
non il pouvait pas être surpris du
contenu quand ils ont sauté et je crois
que ces amendements ils sont préparés en
amont le gouvernement a préparé à
discuter avec les rapporteurs avec les
membres de la commission et une finie le
rôle de la CMP c'est de faire autre que
les deux assemblées se retrouvent sur un
texte sur un texte sur lequel ils sont
d'accord donc c'est tout cela est tout à
fait constitutionnel je vois pas comment
il peut être remis en cause de la
sincérité c'est la première fois que je
vois une remise en cause d'une CMP c'est
la première fois et parce que c'est la
première
des représentants d'une des deux
assemblées n'a jamais vu le fait que
l'assemblée n'est pas voté toutes les
règles constitutionnelles ont été
respectées s'il a pas voté c'est qu'elle
n'a pas voulu voter ce qu'elle n'a pas
voulu voter elle a tout fait pour ne pas
voter ne pas venir après de dire j'ai
pas voté bon on avance un peu sur le
fond est-ce que ce Olivier Hainaut ce
texte il porte finalement le saut de la
majorité de droite et de centre au Sénat
alors que donc si oui vous êtes
satisfait je l'ai dit dans la dans la
discussion je trouve que ce texte
quelquefois il y a des excès
d'indignation il faut pas d'excès de
d'enthousiasme non plus c'est un texte
qui assure est garanti la pérennité du
système de répartition moi si j'étais
retraité je me dirais je pousserai un
ouf de soulagement il avec la voix de le
vote de ce texte il est voté et bien il
y a plus de risques de de baisse des
retraites ou de fragilisation du système
de répartition je pense que René Paul
Savary ils sont les actifs les retraités
mais les actifs d'aujourd'hui sont
majoritairement de dire que les avancées
de ce texte aussi par rapport au maire
de famille par rapport aux femmes par
rapport aux carrières donc par rapport
au seniors bon la question c'est que
disons que le dialogue social il faudra
qu'il soit revu approfondie il y a un
après toujours il y a une nécessité de
de loi travail
pour une conférence sociale on peut pas
en rester là on peut pas enjamber non
plus le paritarisme voilà la question
maintenant c'est bien évidemment le vote
de demain mais il y a toujours demain et
un après-demain si j'ose dire et il faut
se projeter notamment sur la loi travail
parce que la question de l'emploi des
seniors c'est une question clé pour la
société française
la majorité l'exécutif va devoir
discuter avec les organisations
syndicales
qui se sont fait marcher dessus pendant
2 mois il faut le dire donc toujours
difficile de retisser de retisser les
fils du dialogue ça a été un débat qui a
été conduit à marche forcée aujourd'hui
c'est pas une grande surprise on
découvre pas que les républicains Sally
à la majorité macroniste pour ressortir
un texte c'était le but de l'opération
et ça avait été annoncé d'ailleurs
conjointement par la première ministre
et par les élus républicains dès début
janvier moi je partage un peu la vie de
François patriar je suis quand même
comme surpris des critiques qui portent
sur la CMP d'un point de vue
institutionnel quand on entend Mathilde
pano la député insoumise qui parle de
magouille quand on entend la sénatrice
que vous avez passé tout à l'heure même
l'humain lui parler de combine c'est un
lieu où député et sénateur tant de se
mettre d'accord un texte donc quand on
jette le discrédit sur l'institution je
parle pas du texte lui-même parce qu'on
peut critiquer ce texte moi je considère
qu'il a été conduit trop vite bâclé qui
a plein de trous dans la raquette bref
ils savent peut-être le régime par la
partition mais c'est un texte
unijambiste parce que il y a qu'un seul
levier qui est activé c'est le travail
désactive pour payer les retraites des
salariés mais qu'on jette le discrédit
de façon institutionnelle sur sur cette
chose MP ça me paraît le début de
quelque chose parce qu'il faut que vous
voyager puisse a reprend une critique
qui exprimait François partie à tout
temps finalement c'est un peu une marque
de faiblesse d'en arriver à attaquer la
fin je repose la question
discrédit sur l'institution
parlementaire et sur la commission
mixparitaire je dis simplement que
beaucoup mettaient de l'espoir et je
pense tout tendance confondues positive
et aussi bien député sénateurs sur la
qualité de la Commission mixparitaire
comme si au fond elle avait pu rattraper
le le manque flagrant de débat à
ressembler puisque on va on peut revenir
mais ça faudrait une émission de deux
heures puisque le débat n'est jamais
allé à son terme donc une commission
mixparitaire qui statue effectivement
normalement c'est fait pour que les deux
assemblées trouvent un compromis la
difficulté des représentants de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est que il n'y
avait pas de texte de l'Assemblée et que
donc la base pour aller vers le
compromis était plus délicate
personnellement j'aurais imaginé que
cette CMP soit conduit de manière
beaucoup plus approfondie et que si les
groupes avaient eu le temps de regarder
y compris les nouvelles rédactions
proposées c'est à dire on peut en CMP
dire fameuse article 7 sur l'âge le
report de l'âge de la retraite de 62 à
64 ans il y avait 18 modifications par
rapport au texte votés par le Sénat donc
c'est vrai que les la façon dont on
délibéré ces 14 parlementaires jamais on
a vu autant de télé de médias suspendus
à savoir si la CMP était conclusive donc
la qualité du travail me semble-t-il est
en cause et c'est pour cela que moi je
ne m'amuse jamais à attaquer institution
mais je dis qu'il y a un problème avec
la façon dont s'est déroulé ce sont
déroulé ces travaux de A à Z
l'une des critiques qui est exprimée et
on l'a entendu d'ailleurs
avec Monique Lubin également parmi les
réactions que nous proposait Jonathan
Dupriez c'est un gouvernement qui je
mets des guillemets c'est couchés devant
les LR est-ce que le macronisme ne
marche plus sur le C de jambes la jambe
gauche et la jambe droite alors je vais
reprendre dans quelle situation
sommes-nous les Français ont donné une
majorité relative au président lui
donnant mission cela de trouver des
compromis pour faire passer les lois qui
veut faire passer bien d'ailleurs ça
m'interroge sur la proportionnelle
future quand je vois comment ça se passe
on dirait que pour en parler non donc à
partir du moment où le gouvernement veut
faire passer un texte et souhaite qu'il
ne fasse passer bien entendu il est
obligé de passer des compromis tantôt
avec la gauche tantôt avec la droite on
l'a vu
de nouveau avec la gauche après cette
séquence ça dépendra des textes moi je
pense qu'il y a des textes sur le
travail les textes éthiques de mailles à
les textes sur la Constitution qui
viendront on peut très bien avec la
gauche trouver des accordons à partir de
là pour trouver un compromis bien
entendu il faut faire des concessions je
vous rappelle que la droite proposait
avec son amendement chaque année une
réforme à 65 ans sec
là on est parti de 65 là ils n'ont pas
voulu il est arrivé à 64 premier
compromis ensuite on est arrivé sur le
stock des minimum de pension puis on est
arrivé sur les carrières longues ça veut
dire que pour arriver à pour arriver à
se compromis il faut bien un moment
trouver un point d'équilibre et faire
des concessions donc le gouvernement
c'est pas couché il a je pense
intelligemment négocié la droite et la
droite j'entends bien j'entends bien un
discours aujourd'hui mais pour faire
parler du texte et dire simplement à
Marie-Pierre que c'est vrai que le texte
n'a pas été voté mais la loi prévoit que
si le texte n'est pas voté à l'assemblée
c'est le texte du Gouvernement qui est
celui de l'assemblée qui doit discuter
avec le Sénat c'est comme ça là c'est
comme ça alors on va se projeter sur les
enjeux évidemment de la journée de
demain et je vous propose une réaction
celle du secrétaire national du Parti
communiste français Fabien Roussel
demain ça va être un moment important
crucial et je me dis qu'il y a peut-être
des députés de droite sont tristes qui
vont se sentir concernés parce qu'une
majorité de leurs électeurs ne veulent
pas de cette réforme et peut-être qu'ils
vont les écouter et peut-être qu'ils
voteront contre et peut-être que ça
changera tout et au moins on pourra se
dire qu'il y a encore dans notre pays
une droite sociale
qui respecte tout le monde du travail
moi j'y crois encore bon Fabien Roussel
s'adresse aux députés mais le sénateur
centriste que vous êtes peut-il entendre
cet appel
non mais on est dans le dans le jeu
parlementaire nous on a discuté d'un
texte on l'a amendé comme on devait le
faire moi je suis pas du tout choqué par
la question des coalitions on n'a pas
l'habitude au fond dans la 5e République
là il y a une majorité relative à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est la place du
Sénat moi je trouve de la générosité
dans steak vis-à-vis des femmes
vis-à-vis des des seniors
mais ce que dit Fabien Roussel c'est que
vous êtes sourd finalement à la
mobilisation de la rue il y avait moins
de monde aujourd'hui lors de cette 8e
journée de mobilisation mais il y a un
sondage au doxa qui sort ce soir si la
réforme est votée si la réforme est
votée il y a quand même plus de six
Français sur 10 qui veulent que le
moulant mouvement social se prolonge et
même se durcisse donc ce que dit Fabien
Roussel c'est ne soyez pas sourds à la
rue mais la démocratie représentative
c'est un moment donné on est élu on a
des convictions une idée mais
pardonnez-moi mais si on est sensible à
la rue sensible à ses électeurs du
moment c'est plutôt de la démagogie que
de la responsabilité c'est donc certains
je ne sais pas je vous le prenez comme
vous voulez et libre à exprimer leur
conviction moi ce texte encore une fois
je crois que d'ailleurs il y aura
d'autres lois il y aura des choses à
améliorer notre système de retraite il
est pas injuste d'aujourd'hui vous voyez
les mêmes excusez-moi mais au moment de
la Réforme Touraine on n'a pas posé
toutes ces questions donc il est
intrinsèquement injuste moi par exemple
j'étais favorable au système de retraite
par point il a pas été au bout j'étais
pour une une réforme non pas
paramétrique mais systémique mais un
moment donné on est devant un enjeu
essentiel qui est celui de la survie de
ce système
sur le les inégalités femmes hommes
pourquoi vous nous dites que le que la
réforme finalement est
favorable ou en en tout cas réduit les
inégalités entre les femmes déjà
autrefois il y avait une gratification
une bonification pour les femmes qui
avaient de trois enfants aujourd'hui
c'est au premier enfant 5% c'est pas une
petite histoire toutes les toutes les
femmes qui nous regardent peuvent se
dire ça qui vont prendre leur retraite
deuxièmement il y a un certain nombre de
trimestres qui n'étaient pas validé à
l'occasion de des congés maternité ou à
l'occasion des carrières hachées et et
tout ça fait on fait en sorte de
rapprocher la retraite des hommes et la
retraite des femmes ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas des petites avancées et quant
à la réforme elle-même par rapport à la
réforme Touraine elle touche en réalité
non pas la totalité des Français qui
vont prendre leur retraite mais si
françaises ou si Français sur dix il y
en a quatre sur 10 les les souvent les
plus les plus fragiles ou les plus
modestes qui ne sont pas touchés par
cette réforme du fait des des avancées
sociales par rapport à la réforme
Touraine ça doit quand même être dit ça
n'est pas suffisamment expliqué
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie que sur la
question de de l'égalité famome vous
voyez ticket tout à l'heure pendant que
que
cette réforme était formidable même si
j'entends la prudence de son propos
était favorable aux femmes parce que ça
a été suffisamment dit la question du
nombre de trimestres la question de
l'âge du report à 64 ans le fait que les
trimestres de de maternité finalement
devenaient inutile dès lors qu'il y
avait cette limite d'âge nécessaire à 64
ans faisait que de fait les femmes qui
avaient une carrière hachée plus souvent
que les autres en été les premières
victimes on a vu aussi tout le débat sur
la fameuse retraite à 1200 euros comment
est-ce que le gouvernement s'est pris
les pieds dans le tapis pour expliquer
début janvier je retrouvais les
déclarations de certains disons qu'il y
aurait 2 millions de bénéficiaires pour
finalement finir dans un courrier qui a
envoyé Olivier du soft au député à 13000
donc les gens n'y comprennent plus rien
j'indique par ailleurs c'est un détail
quoi que au Sénat il y a quand même eu
44 sénateurs de droite ou qui n'ont pas
voté le texte donc ça a troublé y
compris dans l'esprit de certains
sénateurs vous avez sorti la calculette
pour savoir combien de députés LR ou
voté
ce soin au gouvernement et au moins
l'assemblée je pense j'ai toujours pensé
un avec le texte serait voté au Sénat
entre l'option qui était de repousser
pour ne pas voter le texte de
l'opposition et la volonté de la
majorité du Sénat d'avoir un texte voté
on a eu je pensais que la CMP serait
positive je demeure optimise pour dire
que ce texte de loi de maths passera
149-3 bon ce sera un constat d'échecs
il faut la voter jamais il y avait pas
de majorité évidente je serai pas choqué
qu'elle 49-3 parce que le pire des
échecs ce serait qui est pas loin ce
serait qui est pas de loi alors
j'entends bien de dire
répondre à la demande populaire tout à
l'heure vous avez posé la question oui
j'entends mais si à chaque fois écoutez
bien c'est dans ce pays à chaque fois
qu'il y a un million de personnes dans
la rue le gouvernement retire sa loi je
suis pas sûr qu'on votera des lois
courageuse demain pour redresser les
finances et
tout le monde il y a une démocratie
représentative tout à fait il y a une
démocratie sociale avec des gens qui
sont quand même élus par des Mandans qui
leur confie un mandat et dont la mission
est quand même de défendre l'intérêt des
salariés ces gens-là n'ont pas été
écoutés ils n'ont pas été reçus on a pas
non non on n'a pas discuté c'est
important parce que j'entends cela je
vais vous dire c'est que si on a pas
voté la loi au mois d'octobre comme ça
aurait pu être prévu comme je le
souhaitais dans le pdfss c'est parce que
le chef de l'État a voulu qu'il y ait
deux mois de négociation deux mois de
négociation au poids des fruits
essentiels attendez j'y vais c'est de
moi n'ont pas servi à rien les syndicats
en aparté n'ont pas dit en public on dit
que ce qu'ils avaient obtenu dans cette
négociation étaient les avancées
notoires notamment subergé il a dit
lui-même il a même dit qu'il veut dire
il a pas dit publiquement il était
dirait donc c'est de moi pendant deux
mois plus ça fait quatre ans qu'on parle
de sexe de loi pendant 2 mois on en a
parlé c'est pas le de la réforme donc
pendant deux mois ils ont promené le
chien il ne savait pas
toutes les avancées
64 ans c'est réunir des gens avant de
dévoiler son projet on peut on peut se
réunir plein de fois ça n'est pas une
négociation c'est une discussion une
concertation ce que vous voulez mais
c'est pas une négociation il y a une
négociation sur les éléments là il y a
une négociation elle a eu lieu donc en
plus ça fait 4 ans qu'on en parle on
peut pas me dire que c'est très fort
mais les brutale ça fait quatre ans
qu'on en parle et la boutique à la fin
d'un blond processus les syndicats ont
même été reçu à l'Élysée avant ça veut
dire que la position de Laurent Berger
aujourd'hui elle est totalement
inexplicable injustifié parce que ce que
dit Mathieu on a on fait tous de la
politique depuis un certain temps donc
on connaît les mouvements sociaux on
sait comment est-ce que tel syndicat etc
une inter syndicale complète c'est assez
peu fréquent et qui et sur la durée donc
j'ai que c'est vrai que la démocratie
sociale ça existe s'agit pas de savoir
combien de personnes dans la rue et là
on voit bien que les syndicats y compris
Laurent Berger qui est quand même pas un
gauchiste et chevelu tout ça est bloqué
et quand on parle de la réforme Touraine
intéressant nous on se retrouve la
majorité sénatoriale sur ce texte pour
le système de répartition mais sur la
question du paritarisme et sur la
question de dialogue social on n'a pas
peur de dire c'est une différence que le
compte n'y est pas j'irai même un petit
peu plus loin je pense que c'est un
péché originel n'est pas toujours un
péché mortel mais c'est un péché
originel d'Emmanuel Macron d'avoir
considérer avec peu d'intérêt je suis
prudent dans mon propos les corps
intermédiaires et notamment de ne pas
avoir créé les conditions d'un dialogue
social et d'un paritarisme refondé
rénové c'est-à-dire on est quand même
loin même si cette réforme de la faute
encore une fois mais on est très loin du
modèle drainant et et nous si on propose
une conférence sociale c'est parce qu'il
pense que demain ne peut pas être pareil
qu'aujourd'hui ou pareil qu'hier sur ce
sujet ne serait-ce que pour apaiser la
société française François Patriat quand
il est réélu Emmanuel Macron il dit
qu'il va changer de méthode ça a pas
vraiment été le cas pour cette réforme
des retraites en l'occurrence parce que
justement on aurait pu passer le texte
même avant l'été moi je pensais que
avant l'été il était même de ceux qui
disait dès que les élections sont
passées prennent la réforme des
retraites l'engagement du président
faisons-le à chaud président à vous le
nom il a dit je veux négocier de faire
ça moi j'étais de ceux qui voulait aller
vite oui je voulais aller plus vite vous
voulez aller plus vite
position à l'époque donc non le
Président il a dit non je veux à tout
prix qui attend de négociation François
bayroule a demandé souvenez-vous on a
parlé de ce rendez-vous il a dit
laissons le temps de négociation je
voudrais vous dire quand même quand
j'entends dire que ce gouvernement
engendre les sadique aujourd'hui le
paritarisme il n'a pas semblé que ni
pour la réforme Touraine ni pour la
réforme souillon il y a eu plus de
négociations par rapport au
désorientales discuter avec la CFDT ah
bah oui
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que à
partir du moment où on était explicite
que l'engagement était de dire 65 64 et
on les syndicats ont dit vous pouvez
nous dire tout ce que vous voulez nous
on discutera pas parce que c'est 64
c'est pas forcément la faute du
gouvernement alors je vais revenir à
l'essence même de de cette réforme
presque sa philosophie travaille plus
pourquoi c'est indispensable selon vous
ah bah ça c'est c'est pour des raisons
il y a un sénateur mais je dirais pas
son nom qu'à un moment donné et dit
quand on aime les chi quand on n'aime
pas les chiffres on peut pas aimer les
les gens comme il est pas là j'ai pas
cité son nom mais il était il siège sur
les les rangs des dans les rangs des
Verts non bah la question elle est elle
est malheureusement impitoyable
démographique vous avez un système de
répartition il faut forcément que les
cotisants viennent équilibrer les
retraites de de ceux qui prennent leur
retraite vous aviez auparavant
et s'endetter pour payer nos retraites
c'est pas responsable tout de même
Franck pierre de la contribuera 30
millions de retraités en 2030 mais il y
a trois manques dans le raisonnement
d'Olivier Hainaut le premier c'est que
la droite elle est centristes et les
macronistes ont toujours refusé de
prendre de face le problème des recettes
parce que le problème des retraites
c'est un problème de recettes et donc
refuser d'élargir le champ de réflexion
on a fait beaucoup de propositions pour
trouver de nouvelles recettes le
deuxième point c'est que on a affaire à
une situation démographique et
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons effectivement
un pic de dépenses de retraite parce que
Peppy boom qu'on avait avant baby-boom
et que on peut le regretter mais un
certain nombre de ceux qui sont nés
après la guerre ne seront pris des
nôtres et donc voilà la troisième chose
sur lequel on fait l'impasse et qui fait
que le raisonnement d'Olivier Hainaut
n'est pas totalement complet c'est le
chômage des des personnes qui sont
justement jusqu'à 64 ans donc moi je
veux bien qu'on raconte que on va avoir
plus de cotisations parce qu'on aura
plus de gens qui travailleront sauf que
c'est faux et donc c'est d'ailleurs bien
ce qu'a essayé de traiter la droite au
Sénat en se disant voilà vous n'y est
pas cette situation et ce problème les
gens plus âgés qu'on appelle des seniors
alors la notion de Seigneur est variable
selon les métiers les indicateurs etc
mais en gros au-delà de 57 ans et bien
ils n'ont pas de travail donc que
vont-ils devenir entre 62 et 64 ans ils
n'auront pas davantage de travail vous
avez réformé le système d'assurance
chômage donc ils n'auront même plus
droit à l'assurance chômage donc ils
vont se retrouver avec les minima
sociaux le RSA etc et ça ce n'est pas
votre CDI seniors qui d'ailleurs s'est
rabougri au cours de la CMP qui va
traiter sujet donc on voit bien que la
préhension de l'ensemble du sujet n'est
pas complet et ne permet pas de résoudre
le problème François patriargument
démographique il est il est simple à
comprendre pourquoi il a pas convaincu
les fautes c'est ça j'ai expliqué à
plusieurs reprises sur ce plateau que
nous avons aujourd'hui 17 millions de
retraités et qu'il y en aurait 20
millions en 2030 20 millions bien
moi j'ai lu 30 millions dans un article
de Raphaël Legendre dans l'opinion mais
bon donc c'est 3 millions de plus donc
ça veut dire déjà ça veut dire déjà
qu'il y aura un tiers des Français qui
sont en retraite est-ce que vous pensez
qu'avec un tiers des Français en
retraite la France peut travailler moins
non travaillons pourra pas travailler
moins on a pu faire leur tête à 60 ans
parce que la démographie était pour nous
alors Marie-Pierre explique tous les
pays qui ont augmenté parce qu'on se
connaît depuis longtemps
entre sénateurs
même parti en plus on peut on peut être
opposé et puis se respecter
ici s'apprécie humainement donc voilà
donc je veux dire et j'ai beaucoup
d'estime pour me faire comme
Marie-Pierre delacanterie bon donc il y
a pas là c'est que Marie-Pierre je viens
de redis tous les pays qui ont reculé
l'âge de la retraite en même temps
permis l'employabilité des seniors plus
on remonte dans les attrapeutes plus les
seigneurs travaillent c'est dans tous
les pays ça a été prouvé en Allemagne
partout donc il travaille plus donc là
l'objection maintenant travailler plus
c'est vrai chéri d'abord c'est parce que
la retraite par répartition c'est c'est
pas l'impôt c'est un cotisant pour un
truc mais surtout travailler plus
pourquoi parce qu'en travaillant en plus
en quoi qu'ils ont plus on va créer plus
de richesses et si on veut aujourd'hui
répondre aux autres défis travail en
travail en plus pour demain l'éducation
la santé etc on pourra peut-être avec ça
dégager des marges de manœuvre pour
maintenir les services publics mieux
éduquer les gens mieux les défendre mais
plus de justice et le faire à côté
Mathieu le problème c'est que ça ne pose
pas de souci de travailler plus
c'est une réforme qui a été pensée par
des gens qui ont pas de souci pour des
gens qui ont pas de souci et
autour de cette table travailler deux
ans de plus quand on a démarré sa vie
professionnelle un peu plus tard quand
on a un boulot de cadre quand on a un
boulot administratif on est des gens
quand on a un niveau de rémunération qui
est le plus élevé on est des gens qui
n'ont pas de souci mais le réel comme
des vacances et quand on se cogne et
dans le réel il y a des gens qui ont des
soucis il y a des gens qui ont des
carrières hachées il y a des gens qui
ont des tout petits salaires il y a des
gens qui ont des conditions de travail
avec des soucis et tout ça je pense que
ça n'a pas été vu par ailleurs il y a
quand même un coin aveugle terrible sur
ce problème de financement c'est que le
choix était fait de ne faire porter la
charge de cette réforme que sur les sols
actifs c'est un choix qu'il faut assumer
on dit c'est vous qu'on fait payer et
basta jamais il n'a été envisagé de
d'augmenter ne serait-ce qu'un peu le
montant des cotisations parce qu'on
rappelle que qu'est-ce qui finance le
système de retraite c'est les
cotisations aussi
parce qu'il y a un dogme qui fait que le
il faut baisser sans cesse le coût du
travail on appelle ça des charges
sociales c'est un dogme alors après il y
en a qui disent oui mais sur les
augmente trop on pourra plus créer
d'emploi donc mais il y a peut-être une
juste mesure ce dossier là n'a même pas
été examiné il n'était pas question une
autre question se pose sur le niveau des
pensions alors là on dit ah ben non au
niveau des pensions on peut pas y
toucher oui mais aujourd'hui vieillesse
n'est plus synonyme de pauvreté c'était
le cas dans les années 70 quand on a mis
en place par exemple le minimum
vieillesse je ne dis pas que les
personnes âgées sont riches c'est pas ça
mais il y a des actifs qui ont des
niveaux de vie qui sont globalement
similaires à ceux des retraités c'est
pas c'est pas une réforme où tout le
monde fait un effort c'est pas une
réforme on a tout envisagé je parle même
pas si est-ce qu'il faut financer par de
nouveaux impôts je sais pas quoi mais
c'est une réforme où on a actionné un
seul levier en considérant que allez ça
va pas te poser de problème partout
ailleurs tout le monde travaille un peu
plus et voilà nous ça nous poserait pas
de problème de travailler plus bon on va
parler des des chiffres et des objectifs
initiaux je propose à Mathias ça reste
de nous rejoindre tout de suite sur sur
ce plateau bonsoir Mathias bienvenue à
vous peut-être évoqué le bilan comptable
on va dire de ce à du texte ressorti de
la commission mixparitaire est-ce que
des lignes budgétaires ont bougé on le
savait Thomas c'était la boussole du
gouvernement objectif équilibré à
l'horizon 2030 le report de l'âge de 62
à 64 ans doit faire économiser quelques
18 milliards alors les mesures
d'adoucissement dans le texte du
gouvernement prévoyait des dépenses à
hauteur de 5 milliards l'idée étant de
combler un déficit prévisionnel de 13
milliards souvenez-vous c'est la fameuse
formule que Martel Gabriel Attal la
réforme ou la faillite pourtant la
recherche d'une majorité aussi bien à
l'Assemblée cosena obligé l'exécutif à
lâcher du lest sur des mesures je cite
de justice sociale permettant de rendre
moins brutal la réforme donc oui des
lignes budgétaires ont bougé mais
toujours avec cette recherche
d'équilibre allez on donne des exemples
allez ces aménagements viennent à 99%
des républicains avant la CMP déjà il y
avait eu une concession faite au LR pour
les 20 21 ans la possibilité de partir
après 43 nuités 400 millions d'euros
l'amendement marlex qui a été paquet
aujourd'hui pour laisser partir après 43
ans nuités une partie de celles et ceux
qui auraient cumulé 4 à 5 trimestres
avant leur 21 ans une mesure à 300
millions d'euros et pour les concessions
faites au sénateur on peut citer la
surcotte des mers de famille estimée à
environ 300 millions d'euros ou encore
le CDI senior qui s'il venait à être
appliqué au-delà de l'expérimentation
jusqu'en 2026 pour écouter entre 700 et
800 millions d'euros donc vous savez
sorti la calculette on arrive à quelle
somme et bien si on additionne les
mesures que je viens de vous citer on
s'approche des 2 milliards d'euros pour
une réforme qui ambitionnait d'en
trouver un peu plus de 13 ce n'est donc
pas une mince affaire le système devrait
donc être légèrement déficitaire en 2030
de quelques centaines de millions
d'euros mais le gouvernement l'assure
avec cette réforme les retraites par
répartition sont sauvées merci aussi
Mathias est-ce que cette réforme va
suffire ce qui va pas falloir en faire
une autre d'ici 5 ans finalement
François patriar sur les chiffres
aujourd'hui c'est que la réforme elle
permet de gagner 17 milliards et demi
j'y rajoute sur ce qui est pris 10
milliards 3
et j'y rajoute les 1 milliards 3 qui
vont être pris sur la caisse vous avez
pas la même question
le gouvernement pense que cette réforme
en fin de compte on approche les 20
milliards parce qu'il y a une partie
accident du travail la vie
professionnelle une partie scénarcelle
20 milliard alors on va dire 19
milliards c'est la première fois c'est
la première fois non mais ça c'est les
chiffres que donne le ministre que le
mot était confirmé par Matignon c'est
pour la première fois qu'il va y avoir
30% de ses recettes qui vont être
affectées à des mesures sociales la
dernière réforme Touraine était 6 4 6,4
% des recettes on mesure sociale ça veut
dire que on va arriver à 19 milliards il
y en aura 6 ou 7 parce qu'on va revoir
le gouvernement a dit que ce à l'issue
de cette CMP le texte se représentait
équilibré financièrement donc moi je
sais les dernières ajustements ça veut
dire que c'est sans précédent il y aura
donc les 13 milliards et demi pour que
le système en 2030 soit à l'équilibre à
l'équilibre et en plus à ma question
donc vous lui dites il y aura pas il y
aura pas besoin de d'y retourner dans 5
ans moi aujourd'hui je le souhaite je
souhaite voter une retraite qui a le
plus loin que les retraites précédentes
qui ont été votées par le passé la
réponse est bien c'est le corps qui le
donne c'est-à-dire que le corps disait
déjà que cette réforme n'était pas le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites
pardon n'était pas indispensable et
qui aura une décision de 13 milliards en
2027 il le disait oui sauf que on se
projette un tout petit peu plus loin que
ça quand même
pour cent et que et que infini les
choses étaient stabilisées bon donc si
le corps estimait déjà que cette réforme
n'était pas indispensable j'imagine que
du coup la suite ne l'est pas davantage
ici
coalition à une union des gauches
revient au pouvoir vous revenez en
arrière
je ne peux pas vous dire non mais c'est
pas c'est pas une c'est pas une facilité
ou une dérobates je n'en sais rien
d'abord je n'ai toujours pas allô on se
parle je ne connais pas le texte
et je pense qu'on viendra en arrière oui
sur les 64 ans alors moi je sais pas
précédemment
je n'y crois
je dis simplement moi je n'ai jamais
prétendu contrairement à certains de mes
comment on appelle ça amis politique etc
qu'on pouvait revenir à la retraite à 60
ans donc je mets à l'aise tout le monde
bon en revanche je suis absolument
convaincu qu'on pouvait rester à la
retraite à 62 ans donc je pense que nous
reviendrions à la retraite à 62 ans mais
Mathieu on peut dire d'un mot je vous
donne la parole d'un mot ce n'est jamais
arrivé on rappelle le problème c'est
qu'en fait
François Mitterrand était descendu on va
parler depuis la réforme
étaient déjà vivants en 2003
en 2010 c'est la réforme veuve en 2000
après à chaque fois à chaque fois le
problème c'est que les gouvernements en
place la présente comme la mère de
toutes les réformes qui va sauver le
système en fait la vérité c'est qu'il y
a une forme de consensus qui se crée qui
fait que chaque gouvernant prend un
petit bout du problème et pour essayer
de pérenniser le système et ne revient
pas en arrière quand il est au pouvoir
j'ai jamais à ces histoires de réforme
définitives ou mère de réforme parce que
c'est des expressions et en réalité
c'est pour ça que
voilà on stabilise le système de
retraite par répartition pour un bon
moment on a des avancées sociales le
dispositif carrière longue par exemple
il a été inventé en 2003 par Xavier
Bertrand il est toujours là ce
dispositif carrière longue pour ce qui
concerne les femmes et et les maires de
famille et les 5% de bonification je
pense qu'elles vont rester donc il y a
des choses qui vont rester mais en même
temps dire que on va pas toucher au
système de retraite on retouche bien au
système de formation on touche à la
question de la rémunération des salaires
par contre moi il me semble que l'un des
moyens de refonder de rénover de
retisser le la question du tissu social
du paritarisme et du dialogue social
c'est pas seulement de faire une loi
travail classique comme on le ferait
mais c'est d'aborder par le biais d'une
conférence sociale et de proposer aux
syndicats de revoir par notre notre
modèle parce que c'est vrai que on l'a
pas fait avant cette réforme des
retraites ce qu'on n'a pas fait avant il
faut le faire après certains c'est que
on a vécu un déficit de démocratie
sociale absolument massif et que pour
renouer ce qu'a dit Mathieu création de
tout à l'heure pour renouer le dialogue
avec les syndicats bonne chance on l'a
déjà évoqué toujours on verra bien on
verra bien
il nous reste un peu moins de 3-4
minutes je voudrais quand même qu'on
parle de ce alors sans préjugés ce qui
va se passer devant on ne sait pas
est-ce qu'il y aura un vote ou pas sur
le 49 ans on verra bien mais il y a ce
projet peut-être une prochaine étape
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie d'un
référendum d'initiative partagé font un
cinquième des parlementaires 10% des
électeurs c'est quoi à peu près 4
millions 800000 personnes c'est quoi
c'est c'est vraiment votre objectif si
la loi est votée on y travaille
avec voilà avec les organisations
mais d'ailleurs vous avez sans doute
noté que les organisations syndicales
toutes appel à ce référendum et même
François Bayrou c'est dire que vraiment
le bon sens parle voilà donc il faut 185
parlementaires c'est-à-dire que c'est
nécessairement quelque chose de large et
ensuite recueillir les signatures de 4
millions et demi de Français c'est
quelque chose qui intéresse il faut pas
prétendre que c'est un gadget c'est très
long c'est très lourd etc mais nous on
avait initié ce type de procédure pour
la privatisation de l'aéroport de Paris
quelque chose qui est quand même pas
forcément grand public qui avait
rencontré un vrai succès on n'avait pas
eu assez mais quand même la
privatisation n'a jamais eu lieu
finalement François Patriat est-ce que
vous craignez cette cette procédure
les syndicats ont besoin de faire croire
qu'ils vont continuer le combat dire ça
s'arrête là donc il va dire on va en
trouver là
en tout cas si j'en crois dernier
sondage au Texas que je citais tout à
l'heure est pas un gauchiste
d'abord c'est lui qui a demandé à ce
qu'on négocie plus on l'a fait il a
expliqué l'autre jour que il aurait lui
en un mois fait en sorte de négocier
pour que ça soit acceptable bonjour tant
bien il François Bayrou reste François
Bayrou avec tous les talents qu'on lui
connaît et tout l'attachement la
majorité qui est le sien mais non en
l'occurrence on essaye de tendre de
tendre une espérance en disant regardez
c'est pas fini on va y arriver autrement
j'ai du mal à croire que ça puisse
arriver et puis en fin de compte au bout
du compte il fallait imaginer que demain
le système soit au courant déséquilibre
c'est pas les Français qui sera gagnant
dans l'affaire donc je crois que bien
sûr que les syndicats au moins cette loi
c'est vrai vous avez raison de dire
qu'elle a eu le mérite de réunir le
dessin syndicale elle l'a fait bon il
faudrait parce que c'est une mesure
difficile courageuse vous savez moi j'ai
toujours dans ma vie politique au cours
de beaucoup d'années votez pour les
mesures courageuses donc c'est vrai que
c'est plus facile de dire aux gens vous
travaillez au moins vous travaillerez
plus c'est ça on l'a fait alors il y en
a qui peuvent le faire croire encore
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est à l'heure
allez on va terminer là-dessus merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce à ce